welcome to dinner for all the teams who
have to play on Thanksgiving I brought
my famous green bean casserole it's
pretty good but it's not gonna win any
awards I wish we can go out to the bar
tonight like the other James Caan is
doing karaoke we've got some exciting
news in the middle of this grid iron
Heights episode he has for envy our
bundles are starting at 199 during Black
Friday we taste some more pepper hey man
let me take that I think you're finished
pass this around to Clio just passed
left me to toast we may not see all of
you next year what but we love coming
together to friendly competition careful
Matt don't show every page on to them
straight be fancy professional like me
hey Stafford you want seconds oh sure
I'm cold McCoy and I'm still the most
popular quarterback in Texas but if the
East could be mine interception I blame
the fans
Taysom start the car already done sir
hey what exactly is teeth Mills job
Happy Thanksgiving
[Music]
subscribe to this channel and rot your
brain with more episodes YouTube it's a
distraction coach Coach coach wait coach
coach hey wait coach coach goats